foul
[Music]
[Applause]
Tatum and again we we talked about the
Heat's defense in these playoffs number
one in deflections number one in loose
balls but also number one in charges
Jimmy Butler giving up his body he's
done everything tonight in the playoffs
these hustles numbers mean so much don't
they stand
[Music]
[Applause]
Butler is on him
that is off of Miami shot clock at 20.
[Applause]
it's picked up vacuumed in Smart's got
it he slips he finds Tatum Maria just
inside with the whistle on a foul
OMB underneath the rim
[Music]
wow this possession was an adventure
it's the second time under but he loses
it he kicks it
smart gets it but now smart has trouble
he slips going down
to Tatum Tatum's on the floor
but still at the line